hello
persia here and welcome to gamespot live
today i am joined by evan one of the
best gamers on our crew to take on a
very special
live stream challenge powered by truth
our challenge today might sound simple
but
we'll see how well it goes we are doing
a no damage challenge
evan is going to push through the
opening chapters of
ratchet and clank ripped apart and try
not to take
any damage we're gonna have a stop watch
he will stop it and reset it every time
we take damage so we're gonna see how
far
we can get like i said earlier today's
stream is powered by truth
and gaming requires mental sharpness and
vaping nicotine can dull your
performance and
when it comes to something like ratchet
and clank evan's gonna need all the
performance he can get so luckily for
him
he does not vape so he should do pretty
well here
adults and kids who vape were more
likely to report difficulty
concentrating remembering or making
decisions to non-vapers and
that's gonna be everything we need
progressing through these opening
chapters but of course something to
remember is that vaping
nicotine can decrease the amount of
oxygen rich blood received by the
muscles in the
in the body so vaping nicotine is linked
with higher rates of depression
and anxiety and i don't know about you
guys but i don't need any more of that
in my life which is also why
i've quit can't do it got to focus
not only on the games but on life but
anywho evan
are you ready to take on this challenge
today
i'm absolutely ready i'm so excited to
do this
he's excited but deep down he's like oh
my goodness i do not want to get hit
right now
um i'm like nervous for you to be honest
because i've seen
some footage i haven't actually had a
chance to play because unfortunately i
don't have ps5 so thankfully you do so
we can watch some of this action
um but from what i've seen it looks like
it gets a little
chaotic but let's go i think we're ready
to
throw you into the wild of ratchet and
clank
and get this done all right so i'm going
to i made a save file a little bit past
like the tutorial stuff where it's like
throw square to throw the wrench and
stuff like that so we're getting right
into the action here
i'm doing it on rebel agent which is
normal difficulty right in the middle
there
and uh which is fair which is totally
fair
i already saw some people in chat like
is this gonna be one of the
like on the hardest difficulty
absolutely not we're on normal today but
that's fine we've got the stop
watch going i believe in you evans
thank you thank you we are good
get right into it here started the
stopwatch
little little robot dogs are coming up
right on me
you know i usually don't condone harming
robot dogs but for the sake of the
challenge
we gotta do what we gotta do the robo
dogs we are getting taken down today
for the sake of the challenge honestly
there's like a lot of stray projectiles
yeah and stuff flying around too yeah
that's that's my
my biggest fear with this is that like
you know because i'm doing a little bit
of practicing and it's like stuff just
comes up behind you you
don't even see it so jumping around as
you've noticed probably my
my strategy here uh you get a you get an
ability a little bit later called the
phantom dash
um that lets you kind of phase the
reality to dodge which is nice but i do
not have that at the moment
and i have a limited arsenal so a little
bit of a disadvantage now but it is a
little early in the game which is nice
and uh also trying to get as many bolts
as i can so i could buy more weapons and
such as the game goes on
more weapons you have the more you have
at your disposal which is good
yeah it almost feels like some of these
earlier stages might be a little bit
more difficult for the challenge because
you don't have as much
but we were also mentioning earlier that
some of the later levels get
way more chaotic so we'll see
yeah so yes bless the cutscenes
extra time on the clock with those
cousins
i'm not saying anything but you're right
no we take those we take those you're
right absolutely this is great
and for everyone in chad thank you so
much for joining us today we love to see
you guys popping into the stream as
always
much appreciated brandon cj
dion how's it going good morning we're
playing some
ratchet and flink
you know one day when i own a ps5 i'm
going to be able to enjoy this
on my my larger tv
in the comfort right there on the couch
it is absolutely worth it this game is
incredible it looks great i mean it
definitely takes advantage of what the
ps5 can do the riffs are reacting to the
face chords in your club
yeah how does the like haptic feedback
feel in this game right because that's
like
a big part it's to me i think it's it's
a
lot
it's good it definitely feels a lot but
like when you're constantly shooting a
lot of enemies a lot
i've noticed even my hand starts to but
that's good you know it's doing it's
doing its job well
um but yeah it definitely feels
different for every weapon there's like
a half push and a hole push which is
cool
yeah like a pseudo hand workout you know
increasing the tension gotta build up
those fingers for
epic gaming
gary dave says rivet is cool she's the
best female protagonist of all time
i think rivet looks really awesome i
thought it was like
she's going on the thumbnail she's up
it's cool
i to stop i got to reset three things
that was pretty good
in 19 seconds that was pretty good all
things considered i'll take
including that soon but you know we
won't talk about that too much all right
stopwatch has been reset
okay so now time tv is three minutes and
was it 31 seconds i already forgot so i
should write this stuff down
319. there we go we're writing it down
get my notes
time to be 319.
adp says i love the haptic feedback
yeah i think once games got so
graphically advanced
they were like what else can we do
how else can we make this an in-depth
experience yeah i mean again for longer
play sessions i find like my fingers for
after a while but it's really awesome i
mean i think it's a really cool addition
to this game and it makes all the
weapons feel really unique
all right i know these guys pop up i
think
or maybe yeah this is like a danger zone
yeah they were like these yeah these
guys these little
munchie guys that try to bite you
i don't have any more of that okay i'm
just gonna try to
hang back let's get them don't come near
me
all right how's it going robert in the
chat we are playing some ratchet and
clink ripped apart
well evan is playing he is facing our
challenge head on right now
trying to take no damage we're seeing
how far we can get
so far we've gotten to three minutes and
19 seconds
more than halfway there except i can't
math it might be a little less
[Laughter]
it's fine we're getting there no damage
challenge so thank you for stopping by
and tuning in please send evan at your
support
thank you all for coming
nefarious [ __ ] we've got to find a way
up there
the taxis leaving from that stand are
driving right by it
then we better not miss our ride
oh that's awesome austin yeah i have not
had a chance try it out but i already
know i'm gonna really enjoy
playing as rivet when i get a chance
yeah we will play this
very soon
the game kind of goes like one planet
ratchet one planet riveted ratchet oh
nice you know
some games i don't like that format as
much because i'll end up liking one
character more than another
but this one looks like there's a good
balance between the two i love this
conversation i don't know if you can
hear it
oh wait no they spotted me never mind oh
no
we were trying to eavesdrop there's a
great conversation with an affair like
the guy's asking nefarious for more
money he's like this is a dangerous job
i think our team should get more money
and he's like you know what you signed
up for here oh my goodness
i mean i don't think any of us thought
for a second that nefarious had good
managerial skills
oh man yeah i guess that's what happens
when you're evil
uh yeah the thing about with ratchet and
rivet is like they are very similar so
there's
it's like gameplay-wise they're
basically the same and weapons and items
carry over so you
i mean if you like one character's
personality more that's one thing but
like gameplay-wise they're the exact
same
gotcha well that's good then because
then you don't feel like you have to
relearn a whole new character a new move
set
yeah and like upgrades you get for
ratchet you carry over to rivet so like
you don't feel
all right this one's a little tough
we got we've already beat our time to
beat before all right
three minutes and 46 seconds
all right let's let's start with the
chatterbomb but yeah there are a lot of
enemies over here
uh a lot of a lot of uh flying bullets
after all these years just to try it
over the universe
again yeah i kind of wish he was doing a
worse job like whenever i play
spider-man and i have to do a mary jane
mission
i have i despise it i'm like no i want
to swing through the city
like a superhero yeah i don't want to
sneak around
yeah no i totally get that and uh this
game
is not like that although this game also
has fun quips all the time
just randomly stitched in the gameplay
oh i almost got it there
oh yeah that was close this stream
bullets flying at level up
level two yeah so like
as you play through the game you can um
upgrade your weapons the more you use
them and upgrade your character so you
can see now i have 20 health instead of
10 now
ah nice oh i got hit
no almost five minutes
okay so 455 that's the new record
almost five minutes dang we were just
talking about getting that extra health
and i was gonna make a comment about but
it doesn't
because we're not losing any of it but
it just happened immediately i didn't
even have time
that's faith that's karma that's what
everyone calls commentators cursed
before i even spoke
it into existence all right so now we're
gonna do a little boss fight
so wish me luck on that one
collect all the bolts boss fight time
yo robert in the chat we definitely
appreciate you stopping by but
no need to spam my friends we're all
having that chill monday morning
yeah so uh yeah kick back relax
that's my favorite line in the whole
game know giant laser beams no big deal
yeah it's fine we got this
can't hurt me doctor's nefarious maybe
you can we'll see
all right then there's these these
enemies that just show up
purple frog dudes okay they have a
strange
jump pattern right yeah and then you
gotta avoid them and also fight dr
nefarious
oh it's a chill evening for you dave
well
i hope you're having a chill evening
thank you for joining us
wherever you're from tom hall again
kick back and relax and enjoy the show
my friends
brad s says this should be impossible
well
you know i appreciate we've uh made it
pretty far
but evan is a god gamer
all right and i believe that he can make
the impossible
possible not including the last two runs
that we've already reset the clock so
not thinking about that thinking about
the present you know we live in the now
evan's got this he is going to make
the impossible possible yeah yeah
i'm not going to say it out loud because
i don't think so
don't say it no no no no no wait wait oh
that was okay
oh no i'm out of ammo that's i don't
have any more take that
can that oh god oh i did it
um he didn't hit me hello eric
welcome
that is busted wait i need that gun
so whenever i go into a tournament and
i'm about to lose i'm like wait hold up
we have to go to the dimension where i
won this match
okay dang i need that
greetings from chicago that's what's up
i've been to
chicago a beautiful place it was very
cold
actually when i went so greetings hope
you're having a good one
yeah we're having a good time eric also
says hello
evan hello eric i know a lot of eric
i don't know
is that it's not eric tay no um no
another lots of awesome eric's in the
chat
at the moment says good luck have fun
that doesn't count that's a story moment
brad said i beat this on hardest
difficulty and
new game plus on hardest i got a hundred
trolls 100 trophy you got this bro
thank you feels good
this is definitely a good platinum game
too if you're looking to get a platinum
trophy this is definitely
all right also chat cut scene damage
doesn't count because it's out of our
control
thank you
nice we actually have quite a few people
in the chat who have
beaten the game and are also playing it
on mac's difficulty so
shout outs to aussie and uh soul evan oh
another event in the chat
and no oh this evan in the chat
says they beat it no damage yesterday
i'm legendary
so you know you're also named evan that
means some of that power is going to
like transfer over to you
i'll give you my address if you want to
take over for me
all right everyone we're bringing the
other evan in
to complete the challenge hey we have
already passed our last one right you're
at five minutes
five seconds taking all that cutscene
time yeah
only up from here
hello gamer guy welcome thanks for
tuning in
emperor nefarious you have returned
early from your conquest
yes
that's amazing imagine finding the
dimension where you're just
ruler of all things i wouldn't leave
either
yes evil laugh session right to the
title card boom title screen
it's a credit scene that's the end of
the game guys
we did it six minute speed
oh clank
clank
so cool all right imagine though
you think you're the only one of your
kind left in the whole
like existence and then there's another
one
yeah i love this line madness have any
of you seen a little grey robot anywhere
green eyes red antennae oh we have some
long time
ratchet and clank series fans in the
chat
good to hear gamer guy good series
glad they brought it back with ripped
apart
i think that's the coolest part about
next-gen gaming right we get to see
all the old games that how we picture
them in our head
i feel like a lot of the games i go back
and play i'm like i remember this being
different looking but the same but also
i was younger so maybe my imagination
was taking over
yeah totally no and this i mean this
game especially looks incredible uh
especially if you played in like
fidelity mode and you see all those nice
pixels
heck yeah
you know because we care about evan's
mental health we are playing on regular
difficulties
we care very
that much there are two nefariouses now
oh boy i am right there with you brandon
i need a ps5 asap as well
oh i actually look like this cutscene
was in one of the previews right
before the game came out i was like oh
the resistance will not last
i love that she has like glasses but
they're not glasses they're just like
on her a part of her robot being
i think like this is a pearl necklace
like i think that's what that's supposed
to be oh
oh snap rivet and plank
oh my goodness
i need to go after that ship how can i
get off and the plot
thickens for clank at least we already
knew this
happened
yeah i feel that because
i more recently have started more games
on like casual and easy because i want
to like enjoy the story and like go
hunting for side stuff
as well so i feel that you know i have
no shame in playing games on easy
if i need to i am a big advocate of easy
mode
uh definitely i like how some games
you'll play on my card or normal and
you'll die a couple times and they're
like do you want to adjust
the difficulty do you need some help
oh my please game stop
yeah but uh yeah no this game has easier
difficulties which is great
i think the last game i played on
nightmare or like the hardest difficulty
was do maternal
and i was immediately regretting my
decisions the entire run
but i had too much pride to switch it
down a difficulty because i was like
i've already made it this far
i can do it but it was torture yeah
for me it's like i only do if there's
incentive like there's a trophy like
beat the game on the hardest difficulty
otherwise it's like yeah i don't need to
put myself through this
oh oh oh oh
oh they see me they're
all right let's get these guys i know
we're we're at over
10 minutes i know chat is like
let's go i appreciate all the support
thank you
heck yeah all right so i'm doing some of
the side stuff on this planet just
because i remember where all of it is
yeah check it out getting some of the
armor so the side missions
you know does that help you because some
games
what i like to do is over level before i
move on so that the later levels are
super
easy is this the type of game for that
too kind of so
doing the side stuff gets you a number
of different things you can get new
armor and getting
all the pieces of armor in a certain set
will get you certain extra abilities
like more gold bolts collected at once
like
less damage from certain enemies so like
i'm about to get a piece of armor right
now
you can get gold bolts which give you
like sort of cheat code-ish kind of
things where it's like you can get like
no damage taken which don't worry i
won't turn on uh or like infinite ammo
and stuff like that
uh so yeah like i got robot disguise so
it's like damage from nefarious
or enemies decreased by five percent i
think it goes up like 15 or 20 if you
get all three the head
the chest and the boost you can also get
spybots and when you get all 10 spy bots
you get
uh the most powerful weapon in the game
we probably will not get to that point
and i'm not gonna spoil what that is but
if you are a ratchet and clank long time
fan you probably have a general idea
of what that is and i just jump the rest
of the way
i hope so um and then you can also
i think those are the three main
collectibles oh wait hold on
because yeah you can see here there's
like the little spy bots the zero out of
one the gold balls zero out of three
and then the armor the one and one so it
shows you and like you can even see on
my map there's a gold bolt
although we can't get that one just yet
but i will get that before we leave this
planet
um nice and yashoo in the chat actually
brings up a good point there's following
counts and no damage since technically
you didn't take damage just human
error i think for the sake of the
challenge
only damage taken by enemies right you
know if you're jumping down somewhere
that's that's not fair
if you fall to your death though i think
that counts
yeah i'll accept that
but if it's normal fall damage like you
just fell down like a level and tickle
it i don't think that counts
cool i appreciate that
thank you yashu for bringing up that
very important plane i feel like we
might have ran into that at some point
and been like
but no evan's a pro we've also got
second pro evan in chat by proxy to help
so we're good
the more evan's the better if you know
any evidence tell them to pop in the
chat
and come jump we also have a michael
langer in the chat so i think that's
also
that's even more power added to what
you're doing so
we're good you've got this thanks dad
we're at 13 minutes
oh yeah we are 15 minutes looking to go
breezy it says it took me two hours to
finish the final boss on the second
dlc of ultra violence oh my goodness
you know when they came out with the dlc
for that for doom
i was so traumatized by the first run i
had already did that i was like do i
really
want to embark on this i need to
mentally prepare
to do this i haven't yet for the record
but kudos to you
for finishing it for sure that game is
definitely not easy
i i never got around to do maternal it
came out like when all those other games
were coming out in that period of 2020
with like persona 5 royal and no
animal crossing remake like
it was just the one i skipped out on
because there were so many other things
going on
hello sandy good day to you too
nice to see you stopping by we really
appreciate it we hope you're having a
good one
and for everyone who's just stopping by
today's
um stream today's game spot live stream
is
powered by truth and we are taking on
the no
damage challenge here uh in ratchet and
clank ripped apart evan
is taking the reins through this
challenge doing very very well
and while we're here we figure we lay
some facts on you
about vaping which is what we are trying
to promote to quit during this
stream because when it comes to gaming
gaming requires that
mental sharpness and vaping mixing can
dull your performance
so as you can tell evan does not vape
because he is
killing it in this challenge right now
15
minutes officially on the clock no
damage
looking good feeling good so yes guys if
you want to learn more then
definitely check out at truth orange for
more of that information
they also have a really you know i'm
gonna throw this out there they also
have a really nice shop
and some of their merch was super cute
um i'm also wearing one of the truth
shirts i've got these
stylish shades as well someone in the
chat was like nice shades i'm like thank
you i actually really like them
i wear them on my own personal stream
the other day because i was like they're
so cool
everything looks orange but it's great
and that is the truth that is about take
my job
all right i'm trying to get that gold
bolt over there um
okay okay i need to uh time this
correctly because these giant blocks are
in the way
that i can show you guys what uh gold
bolts are oh no
yes we like gold items yes shiny gold
items
all right so i got a gold bolt and this
one you could change like the wrench
skin for example right so it could be
rebel force wasteland gold so i like
gold
so i'm gonna have a gold wrench i like
ghosts
sorry you gotta make a gold member
reference every time you hear the word
gold i just i cannot stop
doing that um
oh snap yeah that's true brandon
hernandez in the chat rocking his truth
shirt
right now because this is not our first
truth
powered gamespot livestream we've had
we've had
quite a few in the past and we've played
awesome games with the community
with other game spot folks like evan and
there was also merch won by some of our
contestants in the past stream so
super thank you for returning to hang
out with us brandon and ow
that was close
but yes so thank you for returning and
checking it out um for those in the chat
asking um quickness and brad we
are on regular you know
unauthorized squishy who do you call in
the squishy robot man
we're extra tanky and buff all right
you know it's like stitch you know
stitches he looks like cute and cuddly
but
he's a monster thing
actually not sure yeshua do you know
evan if uh there's like co-op capability
or
plans for that in the future any sort
not that i believe
no there isn't anything at the moment
and i don't believe they have any plans
for that for this game
that would be cool though playing as
both ratchet and
rivet yeah going through some stuff
oh i got i got hit
18 minutes that was good that was good
that was a long run that was like 18
minutes in like eight seconds
so new record
that's how i'm going to beat i don't
know if i'm going to get that far again
no you got this yeah you're right i
shouldn't doubt myself oh wait i got it
wait you know we were recalibrating
you know we were grieving the loss of
that last run
so that didn't really count yes
i will accept that and there are a lot
of a lot of stray bullets a lot of
things flying at me in every direction
you know i think there was a point in
time where i was like man every game has
dlc but now i'm like man every game has
dlc
like you can never count out that
something cool might come to your game
now
which is kind of exciting oh absolutely
yeah yeah
i was recently playing the expansion
pass they added to ira warriors which
was actually a lot of
new content which is really fun it was
already like 60 hours to 100
complete it but now they've added 10
more hours of stuff
there's a lot going on
oh my god look at this so many lasers
yeah look at all this i don't have a lot
of angles
i gotta dodge this guy's just running
into that box
a nice spot all right chad we need you
to send the energy
right now where's that other heaven
where'd he go
i know heather evan help us out brad
says hide in the back this segment is
very hard i mean
it looks like it i'm not gonna lie i
appreciate the chat with my background
not being like you suck
boom easy only got hit twice
rashad says be careful not to not to get
damaged
that is a very important piece of advice
especially for a no damage challenge
thanks for the reminder got our sponsors
the rounds are getting shorter it's okay
aussie you know
we're recalibrating we're getting back
on track
you know we're taking a little slide i'm
proud of that 18 minute one i mean i
could i could live off
yeah that was a really long run
but i believe we still got quite a bit
of time left in the stream
i believe we can beat that record
all right let's go to club nefarious get
our groove on
club nefarious honestly guys this is an
important
lesson right even if
you take a little damage even if you
resort back to
habits you're trying to quit it's okay
you can keep going
you can recalibrate and get back on
track and
it's not the end of the world you know
it's never the end of trying as long as
you keep going
all right boom
nice we could chill in here for 18
minutes and just
pop you know and get that run back up i
hope a cutscene doesn't randomly trigger
at one point
after being in here for a certain amount
of time that would suck is there a
phantom around here
they're like you're not dancing attack
man they're chilling though oh
no i could have just stayed in here for
the next hour and a half and just
like look i get it for an hour and a
half
success
you know they're all robots and ratchet
isn't you'd think that would be sus you
know you think that would be
that would be pretty obvious
so as someone not familiar with the
entire series
was that character like significance of
the story because
so that's going to know their name right
yeah so this game has a lot of alternate
dimension versions of characters from
like the previous games
that's a character name i believe skid
mcmarks from the
other games who's like a professional
sports player and in this universe he's
a
resistance freedom fighter under a
different name so
interesting alternate dimension versions
of characters so like here i think if
you go in the gallery
there's uh yeah like here's here's the
original skeptic marks
and you can read about like captain cork
and rusty pete
dr nefario that's pretty cool so you get
a little little history lesson if you
need then you see like the ultimate
dimension characters
it's funny because is everyone still
calling him rivet
because he's like i match it well i
think they're like you know like you're
like that other longbacks and he's like
wait hello
okay i thought they were calling him
like they don't really look like
i mean that's their long boxes yes but
yeah they're pretty visually different
well she's the only one back so maybe
she has a disguise on or something yeah
oh my goodness i'm just thinking like
how would i react
to one being in an alternate dimension
i think that would be the end of it for
me i'm in an alternate division
mind immediately blows yeah no it's
definitely crazy
and yeah like for for ratchet you see
all these alternate dimension versions
of all these characters so it's like
wait you're
i know you it's like wait i don't know
you that's kind of a
really cool way to introduce like the
legacy of the series
but also introduce new stuff at the same
time it's like yeah you're meeting this
version of a character
but if you also want to check out their
history then like go read like flavor
text today
that's really cool it's cool because
ripped apart um i think does a pretty
good job of like if you've never played
ratchet and clank getting you into it
but at the same time it's also a sequel
to some of the other games so
it still continues the storyline it's
not like a fresh that's pretty cool
so yeah got a little something for
everybody i'm a big fan of like
time travel alternate dimension stuff
like movies and shows that
incorporate that i'm hooked immediately
totally
yeah back to the future is my favorite
movie
all right so i'm gonna get a gold ball
i know ratchet does walk very stylishly
more more gold
what was it what is this one what do i
get
uh bolt replacement oh this is fun so i
like turned into rubies
from zelda
i think that's really cool like you
could just bring the stage to
you oh i don't want to jump over there
bring it over here
yeah so oh i forgot to mention too like
so bolt replacements you could do
overcharge which is from sunset
overdrive uh you could turn the bolts
into different things and you can get
coins and then i like doing rubies
up here new guys
seraphim in the chat says big props for
attempting
no damage we've made it to 18 minutes so
far that's the longest run but we are
already a third of the way
back to that that's true let's see if i
keep it up at this brad says
oh you got this i believe brad says i
can't wait for the epic speed runs this
game is gonna have
how fast do you think someone will can
beat this game really fast when i first
played it
um i beat it in about eight hours
with cut scenes and just going through
it normally so if you know what you're
doing and you skip the cutscenes
you could probably breeze right through
this game
my favorite thing about speedruns is
the glitches sometimes they can glitch
out certain things and end up on a
different level
it's pretty crazy i think my favorite
speed run game to watch is
battle for bikini bottom like the
original speedruns
it's just so funny looking the way they
glitch through the stages i'm like how
how do you figure this stuff out it's
it's so
intricate you know there's everything i
bet speedrunners don't vape
just saying there's i think for ocarina
of time the speed runs like 20 something
minutes and someone figured out how to
warp from like
the first boss room in the tree to like
gannon just
doing this my goodness i was like i
don't know how to do that
can you even defeat him from like the
first
i don't know whoa i gotta go watch that
now because
i really love that game too yeah i
remember back in the day used to be like
you could do tricks for you like you
could jump backwards and use bombs to
like
moon jump or something and oh my
goodness so interesting as a kid i was
like how do you do that i tried doing it
i couldn't do it
i'll never forget i had ocarina of time
like the gold cartridge
and my brother traded it for a legendary
pokemon card
that ended up being a sticker and it was
the most heartbreaking
like moment of my young life i was just
like devastated
i was like yo where's my game like i got
this
amazing train and it was a sticker
i was like you didn't even check this
card was real
but now i lost my game
and no such a good game heartbreak yeah
so now i have the phantom dash ability
that lets me kind of
phase like this kind of phase out of
existence for a second which is great
for dodging enemies
exactly i know this speed i mean there's
no damage run
i mean i don't think you're gonna take
damage for the rest of the stream that's
my guess what do you guys think in chat
breezy says i wonder what exploits
people are gonna find in the speed run
yes
see my thoughts exactly i'm so curious
because
a lot of these levels and stuff look
like
they've got different like verticality
and everything and i noticed some
speedruns they use that to their
advantage like all the time it's the
only place in the city you're gonna find
a royal starship
i like this guy he's super chill
i gotta grab my gear
mpd just get on that rooftop all the way
across this city that's like hanging in
the air
he knows what he's doing nice level four
once you get a weapon level five it like
upgrades and it's a little better oh
nice
that's cool
i love i love the the rupees now oh i
love that
instead of bolts instant serotonin
breaking the box and then they're just
like
all over the place i love it
they almost look up on me there you
almost got me
what do i have 6 500. i always love
moments like that where
the npc is talking and then you hit them
and then they're like
because you know that the voice actor
recorded the whole line and also
recorded a
moment that they can play wherever the
line goes i don't know why my brain is
like this but i always
think about stuff like that
all right now we can learn about weapon
upgrades
yes all right gotta love some upgrades
you are getting it nice sandy in this
chat says this is
so fun ggc game spot well thank you
thank you
gg see you as well for tuning in much
appreciated
brandon wants to know what is evan's
favorite game of all time
the legend of zelda the wind waker
boom heard it here first branson
okay probably more ammo is probably the
way to go
yes more ammo
shots pierce through anything um nine
echo says did he
show settings for invincibility cheats
no you should not because it's a no
damage challenge
but i guess maybe if people are curious
you can get a gold bolt
later in the game that allows it so you
don't take any damage from anything but
i don't have that yet because it's a
brand new save so i can't even do that
if i wanted to
because we are doing an honorable run
yes
but you know in the game stuff nine echo
there you go also if you've been around
to the beginning you have seen me take
damage
yes we did but we have had progressively
increasing runs right
the first one was three minutes 19
seconds the second one was four minutes
and 55 seconds and the third one was 18
minutes and eight seconds we had a
couple of resets
in there but now we're up to 12 we're
only
six minutes away from beating that first
record evan but this is also a very hard
battle
[Music]
uh so see we'll see all right
we're new and improved we've got the
little dash
we've got the power of evans and langers
in the chat
yes thank you all right okay all right
they're shooting at me they're shooting
at me
no problem mine echo thank you for
tuning in
oh rick wants to know what's your
favorite ratchet in clank gim
probably this one um this one i'll snap
i admittedly haven't played all of them
um i do love a crack in time a lot
on the ps3 um but i i think it's gotta
go to this one
[Music]
that's what's up there you go rick
this is scary oh wait i can do something
yeah branson he didn't even think twice
he knew exactly what his favorite game
was you gotta love it which is all the
winner of your favorite game all the
time my second favorite game of all time
is persona
royal we've got these favorites on deck
at a moment's notice yeah third favorite
of all time
breath of the wild you guys heard that
instant reaction time to his favorite
game that was
power by truth no vaping instant
reactions boom no mental fog
knew exactly the power
i'm hoping that being all the way back
here gives me an advantage
i believe this guy's coming up on me
i know back up we're doing good we're
making good time
boom explosions
oh that was terrifyingly close but we
are good
they're gonna jump across the map
coming up behind me so i see that thing
shooting at me from afar
there's more of them oh my goodness oh
my goodness
oh my goodness nine echo is marvel three
after this right
right
right has been
yeah that was a really good one there's
a lot going on at once
that was 15 minutes oh and these these
guys
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness
yeah only a million enemies but that's
it look at all these
roofies everywhere serotonin everywhere
see this is where i would take damage
because i'm like i must go pick up all
of them
and then i'd run right into somebody the
nice thing is i get them now
well after this
access consoles in that huge statue
nefarious and center of the city
just hook her up and she'll handle the
rest
what are you doing easy peasy
what a chill dude oh
the robo homies how do you expect me to
get to the bazaar from there oh the
ruby's left
no no serotonin
serotonin
[Music]
yay it's bad
i don't know ratchet is that exactly
what you're telling me to do
subtle not subtle hints at where to go
next
this is giving you star wars vibes
interesting
the last jedi
last jedi or in order yeah there we go
i was like wait what's this what's the
name of this game
um yeah before i
move over to that section i'll get the
last gold bolt now that i have the
phantom dash yes
yes we are also trying to get a bunch of
side stuff on the way everyone
and now i have these things
there's one thing i forgot to get so
i'll go grab that right now
um i need to get back
oh isn't it down here
oh snap
yeah it's right here so these little
bears they're called uh crater bears
yeah uh they're named after someone who
worked at insomniac uh i believe
they passed away due to a disease and
you can you can actually buy these bears
i believe
uh and it donates to a cause so i don't
know oh my goodness i need to get one
now
uh you can read our cragar bear guide on
the website which i believe matt
espinelli wrote and i believe he has
more details there so i might have
gotten some things wrong i'm just
talking about my head but uh i believe
that's always been one of my favorite
things in games where they name certain
things after
developers or people or you know
important people and stuff like that
good call-outs i love it i'm definitely
going to look into that
later i'm always a sucker for a good
plushie too on top of that
oh i got hit oh reset it
reset it
yeah hardly fair you know they jump to
you
this is really cool though just hopping
through dimensions
fighting a boss that's the uh power of
the ps5
the instant loading time
[Music]
one day i will own one no
it's unfortunate that uh there's a
semiconductor shortage and everything
going on
oh that saved me
yeah that was that was a close call
right there
hello giovanni and russell
and jay boy how's it going i got hit
hold on
reset again i looked away for a moment
to give shout outs to
our homies in the chat and we had to
reset it's fine
i needed some longer rage ammo i only
had short range stuff so that's my fault
for getting here
i'm recalibrating back on track
creation creation five says this game
gives me super mario galaxy vibe
mark alex he's a great game glad it came
over to switch last year
all right now i get to meet glitch
new friends i love these like petals
flying in your face
so i'm playing on uh i'm playing on
performance rt mode which is uh it's not
fidelity mode which is 4k uh it's like
60fps
and you still see raytracing but it's
kind of like a fluctuating resolution
so um so you will see the 60fps but you
can still see
how detailed ratchet's face is being a
little wet which i think is really cool
the details
i wonder how arachnophobes feel about
this robot you can actually skip this
puzzle if you want
um oh interesting so if you're
if you are not comfortable with it or
for any other reason because also the
sounds of the legs i would assume would
also like
raise them like urban foods
it is very very
this has been a fun stream so far yes it
has brandon thank you so much
jared hello how's it going if you guys
are just joining us today
our stream is powered by truth and
we are pitting evan up against the no
damage challenge in ratchet and clank
ripped apart
we've so far gotten as high as 18
minutes and we are
trying to beat that time by the end of
the stream a few other
important facts though about vaping
that truth is trying to help spread
awareness on is that
adults and kids who vape were more
likely to report difficulty
concentrating remembering or making
decisions the non-vapers and
wow vaping nicotine is actually linked
with higher rates of depression and
anxiety even though a lot of people
think
they can turn to that stuff to do the
opposite but that is
not the case so i'm excited to help
truth power this stream and spread
some knowledge around that to not only
help you guys
you know start a healthier path than
a new path in the year of 2021 but to
also help offer resources which
truth is providing and if you want to
learn more on that then you can go to
thetruth.com they've got everything that
you need to know and
plenty of resources to help you quit
vaping and
i mean when it comes to games and
playing your best and as somebody who
dabbles
dabbles heavily in esports you know you
always gotta have that mental sharpness
we don't want that brain fog or anything
of the sort
you know i do remember a point in time
where there were vaping companies trying
to sponsor teams and
those teams aren't around anymore and i
think that
is basically an example in and of itself
that
it did not help those players and now
you know
gaming has kind of like pushed them out
as well so i think gamers know they
already know
so if you guys need any help then you
can go to
thetruth.com for more but now to
our no damage challenge back at it you
know we had a little
cutscene there so i wanted to spit some
facts to you guys in the meantime
but we're back at it again got the
stopwatch running
ratchet is stressed car isn't working
you just gotta go like back to the
future where marty like slammed his head
on the wheel and then
so like in that moment when the ship
went off like the controller like you
could feel the
rumbling which is really cool
so now we could play as rivet
oh i'm excited okay like the mom and
i've been waiting for him i guess
because you know i've seen a lot of
preview footage of these like earlier
levels not quite this far
but haven't been able to see as much of
rivets
in action by dr nefarious who used it to
bring
you here now you just have to find your
friend who is
also miraculously a lombax
to save the day and get home
you must seriously think i'm an idiot
look
as real as i'm sure this dr nefarious is
this has the emperor written all over it
oh right because he's the emperor over
there
in her world so there's dr nefarious
from wrestling yeah
then there's emperor nefarious from
rivets oh
not looking out you're definitely not
looking up it's okay
it's a pretty strong ship though because
it didn't explode
on impact absolutely but here we are
i was gonna take you to my hideout
but first thanks sandy i appreciate it
ruby is cool people say she is cute she
is adorable
and also kicking butt like what more can
you ask for
totally i also really just love her
color palette oh yeah it looks so nice
yes some beauty shots photo mode
some some close-ups
i know one hour of photo mode no
damage none photo mode no damage
no tool assistant speedrun
[Music]
oh my goodness all these frogs one
unfortunate jump
yeah i know when they hit me i came over
here to get them ahead of time because
if you keep going they'll like run after
you
oh no oh that scared me i thought they
were
frogs i still see them jumping around
oh no wait i got hit that one hit me
gotta reset
the frog we knew it yeah i knew that
game we knew
commentators cursed again i just need to
stop
nah it's fine they come from behind you
what can you do you don't even know all
right
so this part oh what are you doing
um all right hopefully i don't get hit
by these things
they like shoot something at you that
whatever that green stuff is
the goo yeah yeah they take a lot of
hits
to go so yeah
they are a little tanky yeah at least
it's a little bit of like a rainbow shot
instead of a straight
shot but still definitely helpful
oh okay hopefully i can hit him come
over here
hello super welcome bivton
hello they said persia bibton
what's up good morning well
in a couple minutes for me good
afternoon wherever you guys reside i
hope you're having a good day
we are playing some ratchet and clank
wrist apart and by we i mean
evan facing off against this no damage
challenge
right now the time to beat for us is 18
minutes
and we've got plenty of time to beat
that record i set the bar really high
for myself
i like how we still tried to tell her
what it was even though he doesn't know
he was like
somehow
a riff pocket though that's a pretty
good like on the spot name for whatever
this is
yeah it's like because the dimensions
are all screwed up uh
there's like these little pockets which
for some reason have armor in them that
you can get
you know always time for a little bit of
stylin
how's the weather in san fran amazing
actually it's like 60 degrees
partly cloudy slight breeze coming in
from the northwest you know
all that good i have no idea that's what
it really is but
it's been nice i know there's been a
massive heat wave
kind of going across the country in
various places but it's been pretty
chill up here
for sure it's super hot in l.a yeah i
bet
i bet all right i might get hit
here just doing this fetal thing
nah you got this we have the
these non-vaping reactions evan i
believe
you're right i appreciate the support
we got the timer on right now
nine seconds to get over there evan
yeah then there's that thing that blows
up
and then it hits the ground and then it
blows up which is not fun
and it's hard to dodge properly
got this pro gamer reactions our
resident
ratchet and clank expert going toe to
toe
with i don't even know what these guys
are called but don't either
[Applause]
she always believed i agree
always believed and hello good afternoon
at vinnie pawn
nice i think that's easy
oh yeah leveling up slow motion
serotonin right there that was nice
the roommates were like didn't get it
you're professional you know only real
gamers
in this house yes exactly we are the
game spot after all uh
what it is all i know is it keeps
getting bigger
between that never a good time
don't worry i'll take care of it oh and
to keep you all busy while i'm gone
got this exercise
yourself once you get her from that
purple mess over there
she said now you give it to her because
i ain't going in there
you're okay fair it's totally fair
i'm you know i respect that she does not
get paid enough
to go in there for here
okay
oh okay
now i have more weapons which is nice uh
but now it's a nice little
shopkeeper yeah now you do a fun little
puzzle so i don't believe there's a way
to get hit doing this
let's not jinx it now
i think i could fall off a cliff maybe
oh
all right well no that's not gonna
happen
[Music]
resident professional
greetings welcome wow how did you get in
here
where exactly is um oh man i love the
way this looks
oh yeah this looks great
i'm a sucker for like spacey galaxy
themed
type thing so everything is a total vibe
right now
final tell oh
oh dear oh well i am clang
please allow me to help right yes flank
i am the all-seeing cosmic prophet of
inter-dimensional sector 2255
phase omega
shoulder wiggles
uh i'm not gonna take any damage
would you like to help me fix the
dimensions
all right so these are really fun these
are little puzzles where you have to
guide all these
clanks to the goal at the end
you can collect these orbs so like for
example that shoots them up higher
and then you see they're all like
jumping into the box
so now i have to break the boxes so they
get that out of their way
and then they get hit by this thing and
then that opens the door
they've lost their way if you can guide
them to the meta terminal ahead
you'll begin to repair this anomaly
now you'll enter the meta terminal and
you'll be one step closer
this is like a modern version of that
like water
pipe game where you got to like turn all
the pipes to make the water flow to the
other
totally but like super hd
5d sixth eighth sense realism version of
that
you know exactly
actually i've been studying in the
archives no
brad said my favorite feature is
skipping these on new game plus
you can in fact skip these yeah which is
actually same with those glitch puzzles
so yeah but you know we're trying to pad
our no damage time here
so we're gonna gladly go through
is that even a word it is today we're
gonna gladly go through it
uh oh and i gotta press this um yeah so
you can like skip a lot of these puzzles
and you can skip cutscenes i mean this
game is your speed running it even if
you're not like really good at it you
could probably kill this game
you seem to be a natural at this plane i
am natural optimistic
i believe there's one more and then i
we're back
little metal footsteps i feel myself
learning
something by completing these puzzles
but i cannot explain what it is they're
good first playthrough yeah for sure i
imagine going through this again on the
second time would be like
not as exciting because you already know
how to do everything that's the thing
about
puzzles like once you figure it out you
can't
un-figure it out so there's something
fun to that though like
when you do that when you do know what
you're doing
of this in the end it has been a long
time since i have been a hero
and with everything that happened with
the dimensionator
i am concerned in times of
seems to be great in my life i've always
found it best
to take things one step at a time and
focus on what's in front of me
all right i think we got it
we are glad that you guys are enjoying
the stream so far
we've been having a pretty good time we
are breaking
up the time right now for our
current run in the no damage challenge
courtesy of this puzzle
we'll be back up to 18 minutes in no
time exactly even though i think this is
the end of it
the real world now
better hide that lemonade before mort
shows up wow
good afternoon hope you're having a good
one
thanks for tuning in and uh yeah scary
dave in the chat said please avoid
spoilers we are playing through but this
is still very early into the game so
some people have not had a chance to
play it all the way through yet so we're
definitely not playing any in-game stuff
today
um i mean i haven't played either
because i don't know ps5 so i also don't
want to see in-game stuff yet but i have
definitely been enjoying these
early levels and seeing the puzzles and
stuff too so
hope you guys have been enjoying it too
yeah and don't worry i
i was doing side stuff as well to
prolong how long it was in earlier
levels
so that i don't too quickly get to the
point when you
find out something i'm going to do a
little bit more specific
i believe there's a gold bolt back here
i don't know if i can get it just yet
but i'm going to try anyways
and fall off
what's going on everyone in chad thanks
for tuning in with us
and sing hello it's always nice to talk
to you guys mohammed
and jesse and he was sorry i probably
mispronounced that but hey guys how's it
going
thanks for tuning in and tuning into our
stream
which is powered by truth today
as we put evan in the no damage
challenge he's been doing really well
actually and getting close to our
longest run yet
at 18 minutes and today we're just
playing
hanging out and helping spread some
important information about
quitting vaping you know a lot of people
don't realize this but
vaping nicotine is linked with higher
rates of depression and anxiety
i mean i already got enough of that i
don't need more so i'm definitely
not looking to vape any nickname
whatsoever anybody else who might be
experiencing a lot of stress right now
and you do they maybe that's something
you should consider if you want more
resources
on that and you know more resources to
actually help you quit
if you're feeling like it's a bit of a
tall task right now which is
understandable it is a big life change
then go to bedtruth.com for more
information
old gamer what is good i want to know as
an old gamer what is your favorite game
i'm very very curious i'm also curious
because you know you have a lot to
choose from you're an old gamer and
you've played
probably a ton of games in your life huh
i gotta know
alex says is this game only available on
ps5 yes
it is currently so uh
we get to sit in jealousy as evan plays
and
we watch
so far so good we're approaching our
15th
minute on this run not trying to jinx
you no pressure evan
don't worry about this there's another
dinosaur right after this dinosaur or
another reason it's a little better
i guess i spoiled the other dinosaur
i mean we're about to run into it fine
it's fine
so i'm about to hit all those enemies
over there it's a really tight space
it's very hard not to get hit
so we'll see how that goes
so you can see now that my pistol is
level five it does three shots at once
yeah oh my goodness so many laser beams
and there's a lot of enemies that show
up right here
oh my goodness if i don't get it here i
would consider that a major
accomplishment
you've got this god gamer
come on i believe
we're good look how professional
no damage you're shooting at me i hear
your gunshots don't know where they're
coming from
the positioning using the environment
to his advantage dodging at every
optimal
moment fighting undercover so he doesn't
get rained down on from above
these are the game making plays from
evan lager
i appreciate the hype
know we're trying out here
[Applause]
that's a big explosion coming out of
your gun right there now the ship is
shooting at me
which i like a lot just shoots this
giant
beam blossom says i have
loved ratchet and clink since going
commando my favorite video game
series nice well so glad you're joining
us today to
watch rift apart
best games tomb raider the last
revelation
oh at 16 minutes 50 seconds
so close there's a lot of a lot of
enemies shooting at me at once
sponges might i add
[Laughter]
well you beat the last run at 15 minutes
so it's true there is improvement
happening here
um we will not be beating the whole game
on stream today we're going to be
playing through some of these earlier
levels and hitting some of the side
quests
because we definitely don't want to
spoil the ending for anybody who hasn't
had a chance to play yet
but we definitely wanted to at least
play and like
well i wanted to watch evan play because
i wanted to play it
so it's all around a win-win for me
today
totally i'm glad you can all be here and
join us
yeah i got hit once which i think is
pretty impressive for this onslaught of
things going on
that is true there was a lot of
projectiles on the screen
jess when you think you're gonna fix the
bridge
it gave up it truly gave up
always got to smash crates
so this one's hard too because there's
another dinosaur and they're all those
frogs jumping around
oh yeah the frogs i feel like of all the
enemies you've saved so far the frogs
are just annoying because they
jump so weird and like quickly yeah they
come
right behind you and you don't even
notice and then it's like i'm focused on
uh getting this dinosaur thing going or
the front door
and then yeah they just come up behind
me and they're like psych you got hit
i know the flank
makes me think about all the times i've
died to a creeper in minecraft because i
didn't hear it until it blew up right
behind me
like what i was so
far away look at this am i about to get
hit right now
oh no oh my goodness
what in the world you know we even got
irl challenges to add to
this show
came up right behind me oh well
yeah see that's the annoying part about
this definitely
yeah see where they're coming from
i'm just gonna keep jumping around not
staying in one spot
get me yeah the schmovements
gotta stay on the move did i get hit
um yes okay i'll reset it
i only knew because i looked at your
health bar and it was 27-30 right or was
that from last time
i reset oh okay okay
okay i see like this is there's oh wait
no
no what uh
what gun do i use
i'm running out of ammo for things
they're coming from everywhere they
won't stop they're
everywhere this is you're almost there
oh yes you know the iconic like
flop that every dinosaur does whenever
they're killed in anything they like
and then flop that's just a classic
dinosaur
death animation apparently
all right i think they're all gone now
nice
trying to find out the truth about you
are you so hesitant to trust me
i mean she don't know you clink
come on just trust any strange robot
that falls into your life you don't just
trust the strange robots that show up
sometimes
although sometimes i feel like i'm more
robot than human whenever i fail those
are you a robot test
so whenever you're logging into
something i'm like i guess
because i can't click all the cars in
this
in this class does that count does that
count
yes that totally counts i think that
thing blew you up
yeah it did you're supposed to jump
across those fast enough that they don't
get you i failed that challenge
oh dean arie in the chat
says now complete the game without
dealing any damage is that even possible
how do you beat the bosses you don't oh
all right okay i think i think that
enemy blew it up
should have took care of him we tried to
dodge him and look what happened
immediate regret
i know i learned my lesson
all right i see you all the way over
there do this now
yeah nip it in the bud real quick yeah
oh no run
run run rivet run run rivet run
run oh
oh okay we made it
tv
yeah when he fell off technically that
wasn't damaged but the box blew up when
he fell off and damaged him
so that technically was the damage
unfortunately the chat though was trying
to have your back they were like
wait i was not damaged which you're
right you're totally right no that's
fine
but the box for that the time don't
worry about it i appreciate the love i
don't
you know good eye though very very good
and good call
we did make that roll earlier that fall
damage didn't count
i want a clank backpack
i would take one of those
this is extremely unnecessary
odin reading his memories
wow this is just some tech you've got
here with it
just perfectly works in clank's head
right what are the odds of that but that
connection is in multiple timelines
i already have enough trouble with usb
[Music]
usbc
micro usb and like i remember with like
the ds there was like a ds
charger and a ds light charger and a
three yeah
seriously too much
i know it might sound crazy but you
think he
is your dimensional counterpart
or something look whatever's going on
here
we're gonna fix it we i thought robots
are
not your thing not all of them just
most you know like the emperor his
stupid followers
pirates
yeah i see the irony too
oh i apologize i did not mean to um
you feel bad even though i just watched
your
brain i know extremely invasive
because you kind of have to try some now
so you can see there's another crater
bear right there on the sofa but we
can't get it yet because we're in the
middle of cutscenes
[Music]
nice fins
[Music]
no
no
[Music]
not like this dang rivet i thought you
felt extra crunchy now you didn't trust
him and then you let him get kidnapped
messed up
ah how's the ties of change
all right so this part's a little tough
because there's a bunch of bombs in the
water
we got this we've got this superior
reaction
i love that her like she's just dangling
off of this thing
like not even writing it just
out of 30. that's okay
oh i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
make that no we're making it
all right another boss fight let's see
if i can also do this not getting it
[Music]
this robot is very weird it's like a
snake but also like
a fish
or like a lobster of some sort
very weird shape yeah
oh my goodness hi in the chat says
this game is more difficult than dark
souls one
what's your take on this
let's just say that so if i get hit
because it seems
like yeah totally absolutely
i mean i can't give an opinion because i
have not played this yet so
i'm only going off of what i visually
see
nice thing is that you could just run
into these enemies
vehicular manslaughter as the old halo
game
call it
i love how it's just like seamless
transition from cutscene again
you don't even know yeah
bring him to a different area to lay
down the pain
and for anyone who's just tuning in to
our live stream today
our stream is powered by truth and we
oh it's okay that was a laser beam right
to the face
well as i was saying the challenge is
not to take
any damage as i just demonstrated for
you just just so people know
yeah that was just for example purposes
once evan does take damage he has to
reset the stopwatch
so far we've gotten up to 18 minutes and
eight seconds which is a pretty strong
run
and you know our stream today is power
by truth where we're trying to help
raise some awareness about
vaping and what it can really do to you
it can
you know has been found to be linked
with higher rates of depression
and anxiety adults and kids who vape
we're more likely to report difficulty
concentrating remembering or making
decisions
than non-vapers and it can dull your
performance which are things we just
do not want when it comes to our games
or when it comes to our health and
right so yes we are powered by truth
today and we
are taken on this challenge and of
course if you guys want
any more information on resources that
are available
to you or even some really cool merch
actually
then go check out thetruth.com you can
also give them a follow on social at
truth orange
but back to ratcheting plank ripped
apart
no damage challenge fresh run here and
we're leveling up we're getting some
some more goodies to help us nice mod
huh
i just love this like wholesome
shopkeeper oh thanks honey
it's great
i don't believe you can get all the
collectibles right away on this planet
you have to come back later
so i will just go move right to the next
one although maybe we can come back
after that one
okay
all right successfully saved our robot
what does it say phantom
captain quantum see you later brandon
thank you so much for tuning in
as always have a good one resistance i'm
posting the emperor's hit list to our
network
come on let's fix that communicator
we've got a dimension to say before the
emperor finds us too
now we can go to scar stew debris field
man this ship is so cool yeah
even though it looked like there was a
crack in the windshield which might not
be safe going into space with
but it is what it is
what's on your mind oh i know he looks
sad
he misses branches
i am feeling a bit responsible for
all of this oh no guilt me
that the dimensions are falling apart
that ratchet and i
are lost oh yeah
well hey your communicator is about to
get fixed so that's
something right
so optimistic or trying to be at least
in the chat but difficult difficulty is
it on we are on normal
you know but it's still still a
challenge quite a challenge
i forget if this is a ramp i could stand
on oh nope they're mine
oh should i take these that doesn't
count that doesn't count we said we said
falling to your destination oh wait or
did we say falling to your death does
count
experiments for this moment that was
testing purposes you know
just
uh oh can i not do this here i don't
know
there we go cool so
shiny what did i get
i'll just photo pack okay that doesn't
help us in our photo mode pack no that's
huge that is
a huge buff just not just not for this
how do i get back oh geez where was the
other ramp
oh right here
so cool yeah all right what else was on
this plane i know a lot of them are tied
to
there are a bunch of uh like battle
challenges on this planet which i will
do as many as i can
so we can see how i don't get hit
you can only do a certain amount at this
early in the game and then you have to
get farther to unlock more of them
so i'll do what i can but before i do
that
i'm just doing some of the stuff but
first
serotonin
i just started playing this game called
the wild at heart
and they have a similar currency system
where you like
can destroy stuff and you pick up nuts
and bolts and stuff like that
and i was like i'm gonna play for like
half an hour
before i go to bed and then like two
hours later when i have thousands of
nuts and bolts currency
i'm like where did my time go there's
just something
so satisfactory about that totally been
there
i remember when i was playing persona 5
for the first time it was like up till 4
5 in the morning just like couldn't put
it down
oh
want to make your enemies go
[Music]
rather
beautiful do you spend much time here
yeah this place is kind of a safe haven
for the resistance
i hope the emperor
and also all your weapons think i'd be
used to that by now
thanks for coming wait you have no
weapons now
yeah so when you're hanging out in this
bar they make it so it's like no weapon
rule so you can't hurt
well we're definitely not taking any
damage in here guys
oh he can smell he's a robot
oh yeah does flank even have a nose
i need a signal booster
[Music]
machine
give me the part did
rusty
[Music]
[Music]
i'll fight you for it i love this
character
she's like let's throw down money match
me 1v1
i
always am an exception oh my god
because i'm living out of fire but yo
you can catch these hands
question why not
where do we sign up here's a fun thing
you guys might enjoy all the windows
over there
oh snap see ratchet wasn't dancing in
the club but
rivet got the moves
so these are little like battle
challenges this one this first one's
required
uh for the story but there'll be a few
more superhero epic landings of course
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so there's another one where enemies
spawn in all corners and they might just
show up behind you and you'd have no
idea
and they're also bullet sponges
always gotta be a dangerous battle arena
yeah it's a video game
[Music]
a lot of things flying in multiple
directions yeah
okay we got this got the schmoves
our weapons are leveling up
[Applause]
we're about to hit the 10 minute mark on
our current run
right we're in good shape right now
mr fungi out there mr fungi will shoot
for you which is nice
notice how uh the pirate guy is not
fighting us he's sending his goons
can you see it i know come at me bro
are you scared
i think it's pierre is his name i
remember that and of course he's
popping off in the back he's like i
would have finished a job by now if i
was down there
sure
popped out of a rib shooting
i'm out of bullets oh no
oh oh that was so close
oh my god it's literally on your toes
personal space yeah you ever heard of
the no
damage challenge right now i have some
respect
[Music]
arena sounds like invader zim yo i
believe that is the same
i think oh is it the same voice actor
oh nice yeah i was like sat back and
thought about it for a moment i was like
wait
it kind of does you're totally right
except you're totally right
really thank you for the call out tower
uh i don't have a lot of ammo
oh man hi in the chat with another
heavy hitting question if ratchet and
plane can pump out 17 games why can't we
get a new jack
jack and baxter game that's a great
question i wish i had the answer for you
i mean i feel like no game
series is out of the realm of
possibility and getting
a new addition especially in today's day
and age so
keep advocating for your favorite
franchise
because you never know yeah i mean you
know the
it was naughty dog right they did jack
and daxter they're doing last of us
and uh sucker punch all right and now
laughs blaspheus hughes
is out the door in people's hands maybe
they have some more scientists
maybe they're gonna make so look at some
other things new jack and dexter now
oh i got him officially unconfirmed by
games
yeah don't i don't know anyone i mean me
and jim ryan get lunch every now and
again but don't listen
uh i got hit so i reset the timer oh
well that was a long run as well we're
getting closer and closer to our 18
minute
uh run yeah 12 and a half minutes
two thirds of the way there it might
actually be physically impossible to
beat that run again
considering the length of our stream but
that's cool
i believe you can make it the rest of
the stream without getting hit i'm
pretty confident that's my new goal
actually
this next battle is also extremely
difficult
all right we need chat to send some
energy
all right and some energy to evan not
only is this guy really hard there are
these flames that shoot up out of the
ground
ah yes fire if you needed a challenge
and this guy also jumps across the stage
by himself
no problems
yeah there's a lot of red stuff on the
screen it's fine
a lot going on this is literally that
name of the dog
who's like everything is fine this is
fine and there's just fire everywhere
oh and he's jumping around and i believe
at one point
those like uh the blades those little
enemies of the blades show up we gotta
avoid those two
they'll be up there there they are
conveniently placed behind you you know
if they saw you're out of ammo you're
like seize the moment
oh what you jumped but i created
sprinklers
you know gilroy just because we did get
hit doesn't mean
we in the stream we got to start again
we gotta keep on going
you can't just give up if you fail one
class
you know that's that's an important
lesson to remember
yeah or four times you know it's fine
it's fine as long as you keep crawling
there's a lot happening at once
need help
oh my goodness there's a lot of stuff on
the screen
yeah i know even i'm having a hard time
keeping up with it all
oh my goodness
all
good
right
we are running out of resources
oh the radius on that explosion
was massive all right that was
deceivingly
far away okay
oh wait ammo okay good what'd i get
names no topiary sprinklers
i needed that
collider
no fire no fire on the ground
there we go okay nice victory
damn yeah that was a tough one that was
a tough one but you know why it happened
you powered through and that's what
matters thank you
thank you
did that
eureka eureka
one day i want to be able to say that
legitimately and throw the papers like
off the balcony and say
thank you love it clink are you okay
where are you uh
[Music]
oh my goodness wait okay i have to tell
you something
dr
but without the dimensionator
i think we have to build a new one
i met a prophet from savage named gary
he would know what to do you've got two
genius long boxes
i think you guys got this absolutely
prime in this dimension yeah why
we can locate the phase chords use the
power of the dimensionator there
if i am right we will be able to
recreate the device
in no time i guess we better get started
then
i'm glad you're okay that camera angle
made him look so lonely
like the empty chair
but they're the same person right
they're just in different realities
so like dimensional counterparts
crazy so cool though
so now we can do some more of these
battle challenges which is probably yeah
i did the first two so we can do defeat
25 goons using only the enforcer all
right let's do it
let's do it words
789 yes we are pitting evan up against
the no damage challenge saying how long
he could make it before
taking any damage our record on this
stream was 18 minutes
so we're trying to keep our next
actually you can beat that record if you
don't take any damage for wrestling okay
i believe i absolutely believe
i appreciate you believing
you know we're leveling up we've got
some new weapons
our enemies are spread out a little bit
in this one
yeah you can't hit me all right
this is intimidating
is what your enemies are saying
right there's
bullets everywhere
oh my goodness
oh that was close
okay all right i know both of them being
surprised and realizing
wow another longbow oh
my they're everywhere they're surrounded
okay all right okay are they behind me
yes
sort of imagine though if you were one
of these goons and you saw this one long
back just taking out everyone you know
i don't know if i'd run out there i'm
not gonna lie
sounds like not a good choice i got hit
oh well oh
three started again
oh my goodness directed
move off of this
hit it platform
these battle arenas they've got our
number
i need help
[Applause]
goons killed 20 of 25.
oh my goodness i mean goons is actually
like my favorite word for like ncc's so
i can get behind it
oh man let's try that again
i know that was really the first time
this gun is not in these are like far
away enemies and this is a shotgun
oh that sounds calculated
which is tough
maybe i should move around more maybe
that was my that was my ultimate dude
but like how you supposed to move around
they're shooting
okay i feel like a big strategy in games
like this for myself is knowing when and
when i
like wins and when i can't trade damage
like sometimes i'll trade some of my
health if it means getting closer to
somebody i need to take out or something
but
yeah the no damage challenge has a whole
another one
hawkeye over there snipes you off of the
walls
insanity what a crazy shot
maybe where's everyone oh my goodness
look at this they're shooting
things that take up half the floor
all right
okay now i'm out of ammo somehow that's
nice
you know the floor is also like the same
color as
like the out of bounds and the
projectiles
so a lot of visuals i'm out of ammo
again
oh here's more over here
[Applause]
go get over here closer to me oh no i
don't want to be in the middle
get over here get over it
our final moments of the stream have not
been kind to evan
but he starts again because he's an
unstoppable forest i got this don't even
trip
wait did i just get hit there i think
they hit me uh yes flying
one string projectile that's the one uh
you know if you if you do the rift
tethers you have the potential of
getting hit as you're flying through
them
i keep running out of ammo oh wait i got
ammo
luckily while i leveled up at this exact
moment i needed oh nice
perfectly timed very lucky
oh okay three more two more
i can do this
boom one more one more
you know he knows the fate get over here
we go here we go
[Laughter]
success success
i think you probably have time for one
more
battle reina the the next one if there's
another one
there is it's like a speed challenge ah
there's one app
maybe two more then yeah which we'll try
to do both we'll see how well i do
i think this one's pretty quick actually
if you can't exactly well you might want
five for you have to go going
[Music]
you know
part of me wants to be able to live
forever so i can see what the future
would look like
imagine you're like oh i gotta go
somewhere take the highway that goes
through the portal
to new york city yeah it's only a five
minute drive
you just take the portal over on
whatever highway i-95 i don't know
roads i would love just like personal
like you everyone has like a code you
can enter and they're like oh
just enter my code and show up my house
across the country it's like okay cool
oh my
goodness that would be so cool
i know i like to hope that hundreds of
years from now from now we will access
that technology
how can i live a hundred or so more
years that was the question
it starts with not vaping guys lately
all right so yeah we could do we do the
last one and then uh
last one is defeat the undead grunthorn
okay i like the way this arena looks
ah yes not creepy looking
at all
[Music]
leveled up
oh
like a dinosaur but just a skeleton
i'm not gonna lie i'm actually really
curious what dinosaurs
actually look like because i think i saw
like a chicken skeleton once and i was
like wow that looks like it's
a dinosaur too who knows what the
dinosaurs really look like
i mean i like the way they look in
jurassic park but it would be cooler if
they were covered in feathers
oh do i have any more no
i am once again asking for ammo
oh nice easy easy
[Music]
easy
all right well done
well done evan this was a super fun
stream
we are oh yeah i gotta end it off with a
couple of dance moves you know
extra stylish we had a super awesome
time today thank you guys so
much for tuning in and watching evan
take on the no damage challenge
for this episode of gamespot live that
is powered by
truth we were out to raise some
awareness about the truths
and the facts behind vaping and the fact
that it can
cause a type of brain fog it can
decrease the amount of oxygen
oxygen-rich blood received by muscles in
the body
it's linked with higher rates of
depression and anxiety
and it can knock you off your game and
that's something we definitely
do not want so if you want more
information on
these facts and resources then just go
check out
thetruth.com and um yeah enjoy
ratcheting plank for those of you out
there playing hope you guys enjoyed our
stream
and i also hope you find the resources
you're looking for
to quit vaping once again evan thank you
so so much
for putting ratchet and clanks with us
and thank you all for tuning in
we will see you next time
you